attendaiattendait de pieent de e
le minisle minise Benoittre Ben.
C'est quC'est qules risqe les rs
à l'arsà l'arsic dégagenic dégar
la Fondela Fondee Horne rie Hori
inquiéteinquiéte: retardr : ret-
développdéveloppentaux cementaus
et l'enfet l'enft, canceant, cat
autres mautres madies. Laladiess
récentesrécentesnt révei ont réé
les crailes craies et sontes eté
bien dbien dngoisses angoiss.es.
- Moi, j- Moi, ji toujou'ai toue
j'allaisj'allaisevenir m revenir
à Rouynà Rouynoranda, -Noranda,s
douté judouté juu'à il squ'à ils
mois.mois.
- Bien, - Bien,  trouve je troua
préoccuppréoccupt, je trant, jea
inquiétainquiéta, je suint, je ,
il faut il faut e ça bouque ça .
- S'il d- S'il d qu'il dit qu'id
la normela normebien, je, bien,r
vivre plvivre pl longtemus long.
- Des gr- Des grpes de coupes ds
demandaidemandait des cient dess
ambitieuambitieus au gouses au ,
notammennotammende baisst de bad
d'émissid'émissi d'arsenon d'arc
à 15 naà 15 nagrammes nogrammese
d'air d'd'air d'i la proici la .
ÉMILIÉMILIROBERT,E ROBERT,
Mères Mères  front dau front dRa
- C'est - C'est e cible une cib,
on s'enton s'entd, parceend, paà
ce niveace nivealà, onu-là, ones
contre lcontre l cancerses canc.
- Le min- Le mintre donnistre dt
jusqu'àjusqu'àinq ans  cinq anse
Horne poHorne po atteindur attee
cet objecet objeif, et rctif, es
concernaconcerna l'atteint l'ate
la normela normeuébécois québéce
3 nanogr3 nanogrmes dansammes dr
Notre-DaNotre-Da, près me, près.
BENOIT CBENOIT CRETTE,HARETTE,
ministreministree l'Envi de l'Et
- Je m'a- Je m'aends àttends àee
la fondela fondee nous prie nous
les prles prhains joochains jost
le moinsle moinse plus r le plut
possiblepossibleun plan , un pla
nous pernous perttre d'amettre e
les 15 nles 15 nogrammesanograms
un premiun premi temps, er tempt
une visiune visi à pluon à plule
pour attpour attndre le eindre .
- La Fon- La Fonrie Hornderie Ht
accueillaccueill avec ouir avece
les orieles orieations pntations
aujourd'aujourd'i et s'ehui et e
à atteià atteire les ondre les s
les plles plusmbitieux ambitieu.
Les gro Les groes de ciupes des
qui ont qui ont ncontré renconte
sont pousont pouant déçurtant d.
NICOLE DNICOLE DGAGNÉESGAGNÉ con
Arrêt Arrêt jets et rejets et i.
- On éta- On éta décourait déco,
les quatles quat, on plere, on s
l'ascensl'ascensr. On s'eur. Ons
les brasles braspuis on , puis t
vraimentvraiment. On s'a... On -
être paêtre paà des ms à des mas
on s'atton s'attdait quaendait e
à mieuxà mieuxue ça. que ça.
Dre MARIDre MARIPIER LEME-PIER ,
HôpitaHôpitade Rouynl de Rouynoa
- Ce qu'- Ce qu' attend on attea
être enêtre enre pour core pours
années bannées bn au-delien au-e
15 nanog15 nanogmmes parrammes e
et cetteet cetteible-là cible-lt
spécifiqspécifiqment sécuement r
les popules poputions vulations.
Donc on Donc on spécifiqa spécit
mentionnmentionnles bébéé les b,
les mamales mama enceintns ence,
les jeunles jeun enfantses enfa.
DIANE DADIANE DAAIRE,LLAIRE,
mairesmaires de Rouyse de RouyNa
- Il res- Il res à voite à voiai
avec la avec la nté publsanté pe
savoir csavoir cst quoi 'est qus
pour la pour la nté de nsanté dn
les ciblles cibl intermées intes
qui seroqui sero définient défi.
- Québec- Québecmettra b émettrt
ses direses direives àctives àae
Horne apHorne apès des rès des s
publiquepublique Des ames. Des u
des injodes injotions ponctionst
forcer lforcer lminièrea minière
à respeà respeer ces octer ces .
Ici É Ici Ése Allarlyse Allard,
Radio-C Radio-Cada, Rouanada, a